hey students welcome to omixlogic as a
biotechnology student you might be
feeling overwhelmed by the amount of
data modern biology relies on if you
look at any job in biomedical research
clinical studies or biotechnology you'll
see that the most successful
professionals have to be tech savvy and
quick with data
data is being generated so fast that
excel can't keep up any longer data in
biomedical research or even agriculture
includes genomics transcriptomics
proteomics or even metagenomics it's a
lot to know about and it's even harder
to know how to analyze independently
that's where omixlogic can help we
designed our portal to equip you with
everything you need like free materials
that explain how omix data is generated
and used big data analytical workflows
that hide complex algorithms behind a
user-friendly interface
curated data sets that demonstrate
analysis used in real-world examples and
mentor-guided training and research
programs to help you learn apply and
troubleshoot your analysis with an
expert mentor
so if you're a student about to graduate
and you plan to look for jobs or apply
for a phd don't wait get started today
by signing up for free schedule a call
with our team to help you select the
right path to stand out from the crowd
our graduates have won numerous awards
have been published in research journals
and accepted to top-tier universities in
the u.s and international programs in
the uk germany india and south america
so why wait join today and you can be
next